american underdog in a theater near you
on christmas day playing brenda warner
is anna paquin and joining me on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line is the man
with the toughest job in acting actually
playing kurt warner one of the most
discerning
breakdown artists of quarterbacking
zachary levi on the rich eisenhower how
are you doing zachary
i'm really well rich thank you man thank
you how are you doing i'm doing uh i'm
doing great thank you i appreciate the
the call here
so oh my god um you know my my
colleagues and i on nfl network we
always make fun of kurt when he's
critical of tom brady and he's critical
of aaron rodgers and he's critical of
this guy
and i thought honestly we have said in
in many many years of talking about this
movie potentially being made we're like
we feel sorry for the actor who's gonna
play kurt we feel sorry for that guy
because
this guy is gonna be broken down and
analyzed so
what was it like zachary to uh play kurt
warner in this film yeah i mean look i
mean
if you're anytime you're trying to take
on doing some biopic where you're
playing a real person it's made
exponentially more
well not necessarily difficult but but
the pressures that you either others put
on you or you put on yourself
um to you know
live up to
somehow very realistically portraying a
person that's very much still alive and
still on television and famous and that
everyone can compare you to that alone
is uh
that keeps you on your toes
but i will say yes i will say that you
know kurt
i think that kurt feels uh a bit more
capable of giving some some critique to
guys in a field that he is a
hall of fame professional uh in
he has a little more liberty to do that
i feel like he knowing that i was now
having to do this acting part of it he
uh he gave me a lot of grace i mean he
was there were definitely days where we
were you know throwing the ball around
and he was like you really gonna throw
it that way
[Laughter]
by the way
but i still got some great advice from
him he he walked me through a lot of
stuff i had this great quarterback coach
and then clint dolezell who played the
college arena and got into the nfl as
well as curry he didn't have the same
you know lustrous career as kurt but
you know i got like a two-month crash
course quarterback camp and
i gave every ounce to it i i would it
was really cool honestly i mean not just
you know learning how to throw
a dime which i do i can throw a dime
here and there okay i can throw a good
ball now um
but uh but beyond that just getting into
the head of a quarterback you know just
really understanding
what is their process what are they
doing how are you calling your plays in
the huddle and uh and and uh bringing
your team to life under center and
guiding them and leading them and
reading your coverage and uh and you
know trying not to telegraph to who to
the coverage which receiver you're going
to all of those things were fascinating
to me and a really cool you know just
skill to learn and i think at the end of
the day i
to the extent that i could i made him
proud i made her proud and that's all i
could hope that is the best zachary and
i got to tell you i'm laughing so hard
because everybody at nfl network and
game day morning if they're not watching
right now when they see this they're
going to be laughing so hard and
certainly me in particular uh having
just laughed at that
uh because nothing cuts deeper when kurt
than than kurt turning to me
and his his response to anything that
i've done either planning on to do or i
just didn't his answer is really
really
that's how you're going to do it
so yeah he could be a cold customer bro
i mean so so you saying like that's the
way he said it i totally hear him right
now i told him
really like he will say that all the
time
and obviously this is such trying to be
nice that's the funny thing about it
he's like one of the nicest guys in the
world and so he's actually trying to be
nice when he gives you this criticism
but you can see right through it because
you can tell that his little his the
perfectionism in him like the hard
worker in him doesn't know how to
communicate other than really that's
what you're going to do with that
okay yeah we'll just break it down let's
break it down
and then i you know and then we we get
on like on a on a football field and i
throw a football to him or attempt to
catch it on live tv which is what makes
my wife cringe more than anything else
um and then when he then when he says
anything anything to do with a physical
attribute when he says that it can be it
can be withering it really can despite
him being one of the warmest sweetest
people he he was he acknowledged that
on the football field he's not a great
athlete
so you know what you can you can hold
him to that okay
i'll take that zachary levi who plays
kurt warner in american underdog here on
the rich eisen show and again it's just
it's a beautiful story about him and
brendo who's one of my favorite people
on the planet as well uh so so dive into
the the love story aspect of this a
little bit kurt and yeah so i mean you
know the the movie is really uh
you know 25 i'd like to say it's like 25
football 75 percent
real life just
just you know family and and you know
and some romance obviously
between him and brenda but also the
struggles the ups and downs the whole
journey of how
to help how curt and brenda and her kids
uh zach and jesse and really the very
special relationship that kurt and zach
even start forging and how that
galvanizes the whole family unit and how
that in turn and his time away from well
you know after college and not making it
with the packers and him kind of like
wandering around in the wilderness uh
and then realize you know stocking
shelves at a grocery store and scrape
and change out of car doors to put gas
in the tank like that is the
journey that the movie takes you on uh
and it's and it's amazing i mean those
were a lot of the things that i didn't
know you know we all knew the bullet
points we all knew this guy who came out
of obscurity uh as a much older rookie
than you would imagine and finally
getting snatched in the nfl for the
first time and takes the team all the
way to the super bowl and wins and the
mvps and all that jazz and you know we
also kind of knew that that stocking
shells at a grocery store bit but it
doesn't go into a lot of detail we
didn't really
know all of the depth of of all of that
stuff and that's that's what makes it
rich that's what makes it i think also
kind of ultimately very relatable i
think everyone can relate to that job
whether it was a supermarket or
something else where you were doing what
you had to do until you could do what
you wanted to do or what you felt like
you were called to do and and that's
what the movie is about and
and of course you know with the backdrop
of the nfl which is so awesome and all
of the uh magical things uh that went on
there and in arena you know the arena uh
uh game was incredible i mean it really
is a fascinating when you break it down
right uh just you know how they
constructed it and how the gameplay went
how different that was from the nfl and
i don't know it was all really fun to
play yeah the photograph that we've been
showing and actually that kurt's been
having you know like he showed this to
me
weeks ago months ago obviously when when
you were shooting
um well is you're you're in the arena
league uniform standing next to the
barnstormers
you know exactly
you know and and how he comes from the
northern iowa university is we always
keep on you know busting his stones and
it is just an amazing story it it really
is truly one of the best sports stories
ever there's no yeah two ways about it
and so were you uh are you a fan of a
specific team at all or when you were
watching it or any years ago um seen it
all play out in 1999 zachary you know i
i and i i say this in all earnestness is
the rams i'm a southern california kid i
grew up rooting for the dodgers uh the
lakers the rams
uh it was obviously you know when i was
a younger kid and we and the rams
decided to migrate to st louis that was
a bummer they're still the rams and i
still get to be one of their most famous
uh quarterbacks which is so cool so now
they're even back in la back into my
home you know town if you will
and playing a hell of a season and the
super bowl is going to be in la this
year and i'm really rooting for those
guys i
i think that uh i think that's you know
stafford amongst many other pickups uh
could really you know put us over the
edge and and we could maybe win i i
don't know there's so much other talent
out there right now i mean it you know
brady could repeat i mean mac and the
patriots you know belichick might have
his hold my beer moment right now like
who knows what's going to happen exactly
uh
it's been a yeah i got i got to pull
from my rams yeah it's wow so you
followed the rams to st louis so you
were a fan watching this scene unfold
and now you're playing kurt warner in
the film version of it that's kind of
crazy zachary it should be man it's
really trippy wow okay so let's let's
get right down to it stuff that i could
use against curt i mean was he like a
helicopter guy around the set like
staring at you or anything like that at
all no not at all i mean maybe a little
more so with the football stuff right no
i mean at the end of the day look we had
great sports producers we had these guys
who
uh do
basically make almost all the best
sports movies they know how to bring
together all of the actual athletes all
of the equipment all of the plays all of
the everything so i think kurt felt you
know very comfortable that was a lot of
that stuff was taken care of and
truthfully you know with the rest of the
story like i'm saying like the meat of
the story the depth and the family and
all that jazz
kurt and brenda were there over half the
the time we were making the film
um and of course you know they might
have a question or a thought here and
there but by and large they were so
supportive they believed in us me and
anna and we had this incredible resource
to go to them
at a moment's notice and say hey you
know in this moment how were you feeling
or what were you thinking you know so i
did not feel like i was being helicopter
parented by kurt okay all right i'll
take that and again like i said brenda's
just uh awesome and i've known him for
years and all of us at nfl network we're
excited about this uh film coming out on
on christmas day and it's a pleasure to
have you on here i'm a big fan of yours
um your work in uh the marvelous mrs
maisel in particular is something that i
really have enjoyed uh
bless you man that means the world to me
thank you rich big fan of yours too fact
fact do we see your character anymore in
that what do you can you can you think
not this season no not this season i
don't look at the end of the day amy
sherman palladino dan palladino those
guys are just mad geniuses and i think
they've created such a delightful show
and every character has its purpose and
i think
i i'm pretty sure that benjamin's
purpose was to show the audience that
even when midge was presented with let's
say quote unquote the perfect guy right
she still had to say no this isn't about
that this is about me going and pursuing
this dream of being you know the most
badass stand-up comic whether male or
female or whatever it is that she's
trying to go prove to the world you know
so you know
look they could i know that amy sherman
pal you know the paladins they also did
gilmore girls i know a lot of those you
know guys circled back into whatever
those romantic interests were or
so maybe if the show goes more seasons
then they they need to serve up a little
more benjamin i i i'd be game man it was
such a delightful time
uh and and all of the departments it's
everyone is so talented over there so
yeah i mean for her to reject a jewish
doctor like that was just a shocker it
was a it was a hell of a plot twist i'll
tell you it had it all bro she could
have had it all oh she could have uh
thanks for the call greatly appreciate
it congrats on the film uh and i can't
wait for everybody to see it on
christmas day american underdog you be
well zachary thank you so much rich
happy holidays you got sammy zachary
levi who has survived being kurt warner
right here on the rich idea
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here